is someone writing for themselves or for
the industry that's a good question
somebody is writing the stories that
they love that they are passionate about
I don't believe in writing to the market
because ultimately you'll always be
behind you know what you're writing now
if you're writing with what's you know
whatever is happening in the industry
right now in six months it's going to be
dated so I think writing to the industry
can be a losing battle while you should
write with an awareness of your audience
who your audience is whether it's
television or film who would watch the
show where does the show belong what
season does this film get released is
this a summer blockbuster is this an
end-of-year movie is this a February
movie is there going to be a movie for
16 to 24 year olds or is it going to be
a movie for 49 year olds and older what
are we talking about you should be aware
of all of those things but you shouldn't
write to them I think the moment that
you try to engineer your work towards
something it loses its brilliance I know
somebody a manager who for a long time
was working with his girlfriend to
engineer script for the blacklist for
the list the blacklist
ultimately that script was never
finished because it was engineered and
the manager then came back and said to
me yeah we tried to engineer it clearly
a bad idea so you have to you have to
listen to your heart song in that sense
you have to really write the original
exciting material that is uniquely yours
that is the story that you're dying to
tell with some awareness of how the
market will and won't receive it so if
you want to write a script that is going
to be full of singing and speaking ills
it's likely going to be a challenge but
if you have to do it do it but write it
in a way that is true for you write
write the story that you want to tell in
a way that is exciting to you but that
can be digested by the market that it's
for
you